- [Narrator] Singapore generated
around 16.3 billion pounds
of solid waste in 2022.
Almost half of that is dumped here,
Singapore's only landfill.
And a portion of Semakau
Landfill is already 90% full.
- Based on our estimate
the island will be
completely filled by 2035.
- [Narrator] Singapore
smaller than the size
of New York City is also one
of the most dense countries
in the world.
So, it's tackling its trash
by turning all of this,
into this in order to prolong
the life of the landfill.
- I mean, where can we
form another landfill?
- [Narrator] The current key
to Singapore's trash
problem is incineration.
(fire whooshing)
While 55% of all waste is
recycled according to the NEA,
42% goes to the waste to energy plants
where it's burned leaving only ash
and 3% of solid waste
to go to the landfill.
For just one incineration site,
trucks collect around 6 million pounds
of municipal solid waste a day.
After weighing it gets dropped off here.
(glass smashing)
- Okay, this is our reception hall.
We have one to 15 numbers gate.
- [Narrator] According to Singapore's,
National Environment Agency,
42% of trash collected in 2021,
went to waste to energy
plants like this one.
There are four active waste
to energy plants in Singapore.
What can be processed at the facility,
moves onto the waste bunker.
At the crane control room,
operators lift massive
amounts of the mixed waste
and feed it into these incinerators,
which reach temperatures of
about 1800 degrees Fahrenheit.
All of the heat from
the waste incineration,
creates steam in the boilers,
which is then converted into electricity,
through these steam turbine generators.
This can generate an export
about 120 megawatts per hour,
which can meet the demand
of about 240,000 households.
- The TuasOne waste-to-energy plant
is one of the highest
electricity generation facility.
- [Narrator] The resulting flue gas
is passed through a
catalytic fabric filter
to remove particles.
According to the EPA,
these incinerator tend to generate,
slightly more greenhouse gas
emissions than natural gas
for the amount of electricity produced
but less than Kohler oil.
- Then the clean gas
go through the ID fan.
Our stacked height is 120 meter.
With online analyzer, it
is continuously monitored.
We maintain the emission
limit within the limit.
- [Narrator] Another
byproduct of the process, ash.
Lots of it.
According to the NEA,
the amount of ash left
is roughly 10% of the
original volume of the waste.
After scrap metal is removed,
the remainder is transported
to the next point
of the process.
- The ashes are loaded at
Tuas Marine Transfer Station,
all the way here takes about four hours.
- [Narrator] Semakau
is located five miles,
south from Singapore.
- Our batch is a huge barge.
It's more than 85 meter long.
It has a cargo of about 3,500 meter
which is equivalent to one
and a half swing pool size.
- [Narrator] In one day,
about 4 million pounds of ash
and non-inconsiderable waste
is transferred here,
loaded into dump trucks
and brought to these cells
for final disposal.
This is considered phase
two of the landfill,
which is still a lagoon,
but phase one.
- This is the phase one
of the landfill cell.
About 90% of this landfill cell
has already completely been filled.
As you can see here,
mostly contains the
incineration bottom ash
and also the non-inconsiderable
waste that we receive
from the mainland Singapore.
- [Narrator] To ensure the
landfill does not contaminate
the surrounding environment,
there are several measures in place
- Over time the landfilling and rains,
will increase the water
level inside the phase two.
So, if the water level increases,
we need to pump some of
the water out to the sea.
Before the waters are
pumped out to the sea,
they are being treated by the
wastewater treatment plant.
- Semakau perimeter bond
is also lined with an impermeable membrane
that prevents leachate from
getting into the outside sea
- Leachate is like, take
it as a coffee powder.
When you have a filter,
you have a coffee powder,
you put the water over it
and over time this water
will start to leak out.
Instead of coffee powder you have here,
it's actually the incinerated bottom ash
and the water is what you call a leachate.
- Semakau Landfills Phase
One was commissioned in 1999.
It's phase two area commissioned in 2015
is currently about 10% filled.
- In the '60s,
before they build waste to energy plants,
the waste actually go to Lorong Halus
and then they dump this.
They go there, they just throw it there
and just bury it.
So, currently we don't have such things,
because all domestic
waste goes to what call,
waste-to-energy plants, which you visited.
So, what they receive from
a big amount of waste,
reduced to ash, that's what comes here.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Incinerations
plants have become more popular
in Europe and Asia,
especially in areas with limited space.
But these plants actually
decreased in number
in the United States
from a hundred and three in
1999 to just over 70 in 2020.
Critics are still
concerned about pollutants
in the incineration process
without proper equipment
and note that it's only
a short-term solution.
With the landfill projected to
be completely filled by 2035,
Singapore has only
delayed the trash crisis.
The country is looking for ways
to recycle incinerated bottom
ash into other materials,
reducing the amount brought to Semakau.
- We're working with local
universities to looking
if it's a possibility to recycle this ash
into new materials,
let's say for roads work.
- [Narrator] The government also hopes
to increase recycling
rates to 70% by 2030,
which requires consumer education.
Currently, about 40% of items placed
in recycling bins cannot
actually be recycled,
due to contamination.
- As part of this focus,
we actually plans to work together
in the areas such as the 3Rs,
which is to reduce,
reuse, as well as recycle.
(upbeat music)